was
[Musik]
als wenn jemand rausgeworfen herzlich
willkommen wir heute mal wieder meine
damen und herren zu einer neuen episode
luca reagieren auf zwei hände unsere
lieblingssendungen feiertags einfach so
viel ist klar 1010 bist so witzig im
schlag du hattest ein selbstgespräch
über persönliche weiterentwicklung der
idee hat im schlaf geredet und hast du
und worin siehst du dass du dich weiter
entwickelt hast
ja klingt genauso wie bei mir nach
weiter zu entwickeln das aufstehen diese
bambus dinge die wir vorher hatten sind
sie gut
vielleicht die falsche schon der da
gerade dabei wird nicht überrascht dass
ich nicht ständig in versuchung
aber ich weiß ja dass ich nicht darf
der bahnhof es geht jetzt auf halo mehr
viel geht es dir gut
ich halte nicht mehr luca ich habe viel
über mich gelernt und ruhe jetzt noch
mehr in mir selbst aber was mir an
dieser erfahrung fehlt ist der aspekt
der versuchung und einblick jesus als
mir an dieser ganzen sache fehlt bin ich
mit sanchez hat er übrigens auf install
angeschrieben
wieso geht es jetzt nach dem break up
keine antwort es gibt hier niemanden für
mich und dieses teil fehlt mir zu meinem
passen also acht so auch die gerade
davon dass ihm dieses sache gar nicht so
richtig schwer vorkommen weil er dort
auf nummer besteht und dann ist es
natürlich nicht schwer
dieser versuchung stand zu halten wenn
die versuchung gar nicht da ist okay das
ist natürlich krass sei aufgeschlossen
und denkt daran wie weit ihr schon
gekommen bist ok danke denkt immer dran
und jetzt noch einen roboter küssen von
hinten kann es doch groll mit bademantel
sein was chloe bei mir fehlt ist dieses
verbale hin und her er kann weder labour
noch flirten und das stößt knapp das hat
chris und so gesagt oder wie also klar
ist ja unsere lampe und sie wollte
eigentlich was von bright nach dem kuss
allerdings gemerkt de irgendwie doch
nicht der ist noch nicht so cool der
kann nicht richtig quatsch neckar nicht
richtig verwerten boot
es scheint nicht in diese kategorie zu
passen
aber vielleicht urteile ich auch zu
schnell der ist doch von reden oder ist
so komisch ohne haley baby
haye liess sie die alles um ihre haut ja
ganz vergessen wisst ihr noch haley
seine frau dana sie gestern
rausgeschmissen
was
[Musik]
wenn jemand rausgeworfen
zufällig ihre hände im außen nichts
vermisst ihr haley ja die wurde übrigens
rausgeschmissen hätte was und jetzt sind
wir in der letzten ich habe dein
bisheriges verhalten hier bewertet konto
positive auswirkungen auf die gruppe als
ganzes ach du kacke darum geht's ja
haley hat irgendwie bisher sei am
allerwenigsten gelernt die ich mit
niemandem so richtig klar gekommen die
hat alle irgendwie gerettet
dann hat sie auch noch absicht nicht die
regel gebrochen nur um den anderen eins
auszuwischen also ich kann es verstehen
lana ich bin voll auf deiner seite ist
ein roboter mit dem ich mich gerade
unterhalten lukas sollte mein ganzes
leben noch mal überdenken ich muss
überhaupt nichts verbessern und lana ist
mir echt egal
hast du versagt
und sie grinst da noch so stell mich ist
eine richtige person die nicht zu nahe
treten vielleicht ist auch noch ohne die
du spielst nicht sehe ich aber die
andere leute früher gemobbt hat und
daran spaß hatte so kommt die hände auf
mich drüber ein konto befolgen der
regeln habt ihr geknutscht
nein haben wir nicht hast du ja menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
raus mit dir weg comeback mehr kleine
zeit im resort ist vorbei
ach du einfach er seit du hast
jazz geheult also dass die jetzt
rausgekriegt jetzt nicht wirklich nicht
erwartet ein passendes ende danke danke
dir du bist ein botanisches plastik wird
einfach und sie geht einfach so
sie kriegt jetzt kein geld hat nichts
gelernt einfach nur kommt verpisst ich
fand die war immer noch sondern für in
der gruppe drin war unterhaltsam aber
vielleicht kommen jetzt noch neue leute
alles ist möglich da stoßen jetzt mit
ihren
die haben gab mit ihren
schminkutensilien gestoßen
du hast euch heute morgen lag etwas in
der luft es war lebensfreude
[Musik]
ja
glaubt ihr es kommt jemand neues ja das
durchdachte fragst lernen eine
kegelförmige freundin übernimmst du
wenn wirklich eine neue person kommt
dann wird es eine geile folge auch wenn
es mich bedrückt hat haley gehen zu
sehen gibt es genügend andere scham
beeinträchtigte beziehungsform optimale
hilfe dringend nötig haben
es kommt wirklich eine neue person
jetzt bin ich aber gespannt und hier
kommen auch schon ein paar exemplare
können die sich jetzt aussuchen wer dazu
stoßen soll
oder kommen alle drei
ordentliche gruppendynamik rein
seht ihr das boot in alle blind das
bekommen jetzt im ernst auch sein brot
angereicht holman fernglas ja wohl mal
ein fernglas auch perfekt er hat ja
schon ich bin nummerngirl beim wachsen
ich liebe es weil er sich gut anfühlt
keiner sollte sich dafür schämen
[Musik]
ich bin wasser techniker teilzeit models
elfi king und ein bett wassertechnik und
teilzeit wurde immer nicht machen wir
nicht
machen wir nicht die organe hey die vm
dass ich nach sechs folgen noch immer
nicht die namen drin aber ich bin model
und stylisten ich bin nur aus einem
grund ihre nachbarn
finde ich jetzt nicht so mittelmäßig
also klar es ist immer so
geschmackssache und es ist auch
verschiedene und blabla aber ich finde
es wirklich der flotte ich bin model ich
bin nur hier wegen den männern ein
bisschen komisch im sommer serie oder
ich zeig dir egal was sollen wir tun
also ich mache was ich will sind echt
gut eingestellt auf die sendung so wie
wenn es ist so arg ist und ich weiß
nicht warum die gruppendynamik das
verstehen uns aber ich würde lügen sind
mir sofort aufgefallen die sind der
wahnsinn
die werden halt auch immer mehr leute so
eine person geht und es kommen drei neue
dazu jedes zwei folgen ist die ganze
anlage davon meine chance zu zeigen wie
ernst es mir mit rondo einer
weiterentwicklung ist ja sie ist positiv
sehe es positiv kann in unserem resound
in eurem server sei nicht das gehört
alles unwissenden jung ich weiß dass es
zur situation kommen hat die mir nicht
gefallen
aber wenn wir uns einig sind und
miteinander reden wird alles gut
ich würde auch die drei neuen leute
einfach so direkt einweisung von wegen
hey wir sind wirklich hier um was lernen
wir wollen hier wirklich nicht die
regeln brechen ich weiß es haben wir
schon gemacht und so weiter und so fort
aber bitte haltet euch auch daran ob das
schlussendlich alles so eingehalten wird
sei mal dahin gestellt das gibt ärger
lydia ist voll mein typ nicht würde sie
sofort kosten ich glaube die werden noch
eine menge geld verspielt in der 22
folgen so groß gute zähne
ich stehe auf hübsche gut gebaute mädels
die labern kann können
die eine steht auf zähne der andere typ
steht auf mädels die lagern können mein
gott wenn er auf mädel steht die larven
können ist dabei die leider unserer
lampe ist auf jeden fall an der
richtigen adresse
meine die kreisstadt tag und nacht aber
immer nur scheiße diese leute die früher
auch so immer sich gemeldet haben im
unterrichten haben einfach keinen
beitrag geleistet dem einfachen und das
wiederholt was die person vorher gesagt
wenn doch mal ein eigenen worten also
das drumherum und paar attraktive mit
dran und so haben sie trotzdem nach eine
bessere note bekommen als man selbst
claudia als die jungen ich wusste nicht
weiter
sie ist hier mein mädel euro
du willst aber nicht ihr typ also ich
weiß ich also ich glaube wirklich
zwischen bereist an diesem neuen core i
und zwischen hey ich hab keinen
speziellen tipp kick braucht nur eine
spirituelle und intellektuelle und diese
nicht warten will
ich freue mich ich freue mich die neuen
kandidaten bringen auf jeden fall
frischen wind in die ganze
gruppendynamik ich glaube matthew also
hier unser jesus wird sich jetzt auch
endlich willkommen fühlen dieser sendung
und ich glaube dass zwischen preis und
chloe auf jeden fall da wird's ein
bisschen kriseln das kannst du schauen
uns aber in der nächsten episode luca
reagiert auf tour händler meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
einen daumen hoch und der medien da
folgt mir auf instagram dass das kann
mich vielleicht dann irgendwann auch mal
sieht hab auch die tagen neues bild
hochgeladen können gern mal jetzt
befinden uns allerdings auch im auto
meiner lieben freunde wenn ihr noch kein
luxus sein also meinen kanal noch nicht
abonniert hat dann klick weil hier oben
auf den smiley drauf ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und wenn ich
schon aber jetzt einen klick auf die
glocke denn dadurch bekommt eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich was neues
hoch laden unter anderem eine tour to
handle the actions wo hier meine letzten
action darauf verlinkt ist sie noch
nicht gesehen habt das gerne an